garé sur le parking pierre-yves a trouvé
la solution pour ne pas rester bloqué
dans les bouchons le soir il est venu en
vannes pour jamais de prier au dépourvu
et vécu 95 cv que 99 plus ces épisodes
neigeux sur sur guyancourt qui sont pas
neutres cette ère que chez les collègues
et qui auraient été amenés à dormir ici
donc quitte à faire autant être autonome
et pouvoir dormir
y compris sur la route pour cette
journée de grève
l'entreprise antemeta a tout prévu
télétravail nuits d'hôtel covoiturage
tout est mis à disposition pour
faciliter les déplacements des salariés
on s'est renseigné auprès de saint
quentin en yvelines auprès de la sncf
auprès même des aéroports pour contrôler
y avoir un état du trafic et ensuite la
communiquer à nos collaborateurs
les prévisions de circulation des
prévisions de train de fermeture de
grève et écoles on leur a demandé de se
rapprocher de leur mairie dans
l'entreprise 45 employés sont en
télétravail soit plus de la moitié
même si les machines à café sont moins
sollicités ronan a quand même souhaité
venir grâce à l'aménagement de son
planning
la flexibilité horaire ça permet aussi
de ne pas lier pour certains et pour moi
dans mon cas précis sur les garderies ou
les centres qui peuvent être en effectif
réduit
arthur responsable informatique est
venue en voiture ce matin
et contrairement à d'habitude il n'a eu
aucun ralentissement sur la route même
s'il a pris quelques dispositions il
craint les prochains jours
cette disposition elles sont ponctuels
et que si ça continue sur plus d'une
semaine je pense qu'après ça va devenir
compliqué si la grève est reconduite
l'entreprise antemeta gardera les mêmes
aménagements pour ses salariés